[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí en
france 24 hablaremos sobre la salud
mental que ha cobrado especial
protagonismo en estos juegos olímpicos
de tokio a raíz del caso de las
gimnastas y bombillos que se retiró de
varias competencias
ante esto surge la pregunta si está se
le está prestando suficiente atención a
la salud mental de los deportistas de
alto rendimiento nos acompaña a sergio
díaz médico fundador de the mind
institute que trabaja en la gestión
mental de los medallistas olímpicos
bienvenidos france24 autor días veces
por estar aquí con nosotros y cuéntenos
cambiará esto el debate sobre la salud
mental en el mundo del deporte
profesional recordemos que este año la
japonesa naomi o saca también puso el
tema en el foco el público ha de tirarse
del roland garros y no querer hacer
frente a las presas de qué opina
hola buenos días yo pienso que se abre
una puerta que se intensifiquen los
trabajos y los programas formativos las
atenciones los cuidados dentro del mundo
del deporte y en general se sigue
expandiendo el mensaje que con esta
pandemia se ha intensificado un poco y
es necesitamos cuidar y tener hábitos de
salud mental que nos protejan mucho más
y que nos prevengan de ello llegar a
escenarios un poco más complejos a causa
de estos problemas o situaciones doctor
sin embargo vemos que hay actitudes
distintas entre los atletas con respecto
al tema y los juegos olímpicos por
ejemplo el tenista novak djokovic hizo
una referencia a la presión y se refirió
a ella como un privilegio porque una
brecha tan grande en las actitudes de
los deportistas
yo pienso que cada quien juzga desde sus
propios zapatos y cuando hablamos de
situaciones de condición mental pues
solamente cada persona camina con lo que
sabe con lo que conoce de sí mismo y a
partir de allí pues a edu los criterios
clínicos y médicos que ayudan a que las
personas comprendan si tienen una
situación y si deben atenderla o no hay
algunas que manejan el estrés la presión
la atención de una forma distinta no
para todos tienen que ser igual no es
una camisa de fuerza
bueno cuéntenos también qué efecto tuvo
tanto la falta de público como la falta
de acompañamiento psicológico en estas
justas olímpicas en los atletas y esto
por supuesto por cuenta de las
restricciones que impone la pandemia de
kobe 19
pues es muy similar a lo que pasa con el
público en general porque se han
afectado nuestras relaciones sociales la
manera como entrena el deportista la
competencia previa la preparación el
hecho de no tener interacción con el
público el estar aislado los protocolos
todo esto va a sumarlo a que para
algunos la carga de estrés seas lo
suficientemente intensa como para ser
incómoda y otros pueden convivir un poco
mejor con ella
sí es cierto que son los juegos atípicos
pero buenos para todo el mundo el último
tiempo ha sido bastante atípico y el
desafío también es sabernos a adaptar
bueno pero también porque pesa tanto el
aspecto mental en los atletas usted cree
que los hemos idealizado demasiado se
espera demasiado de ellos no sólo desde
el punto de vista deportivo sino también
desde el punto de vista comercial
y las dos un poco yo creo que podríamos
humanizar un poco más la industria del
deporte nos vendría bastante bien
finalmente la atleta tiene una persona
detrás de un ser humano
y ese ser humano muchas veces es el
menos atendido a veces admiramos un
montón su capacidad de tener resultados
pero no acompañamos el ser humano que
está detrás de y muchas veces el atento
se queda un poco solo
por falta de formación falta de
acompañamiento no tiene un círculo
primario familiar adecuado y se expone a
muchas cosas también el hecho de que
consiga resultados tan jóvenes el factor
del dinero son algunos elementos que se
pueden convertir en riesgos para algunos
no para todos pero que es importante que
les podamos acompañar mucho mejor bueno
y brevemente alguna recomendación para
los entrenadores deportistas toda la
gente que está en torno a este tema que
estamos analizando hoy para que mejore
la salud mental de los atletas
primero que busquen información porque
hoy hay disponible muchísimas cosas para
entender cómo tener hábitos de salud
mental así como hay hábitos para la
promoción de la salud oral de la misma
forma hay hábitos para la promoción de
la salud mental y desde allí que se
vuelva un tema de la cotidianidad ya no
puede ser esto un tabú no podemos seguir
obviando que tanto las personas
naturales como los deportistas
profesionales pues requieren tener
hábitos que promuevan la salud mental y
que hoy es nuestra responsabilidad es
seguir corriendo la voz hasta que un día
los enseñamos en los colegios ojalá es
importante pues gracias al doctor sergio
díaz médico fundador de the mind
institute quien trabaja con la gestión
mental de los medallistas olímpicos por
estar aquí en tras 24 y usted gracias
por estar con nosotros continúen con más
entra al 24 punto com
[Música]